[Musik]
hallo zusammen heute machen wir wieder
einen saftigen Klassiker bei trockenen
Kuchen denkt man ja immer so unsere
dröge Kuchen die man den Kaffee tunken
muss aber so ist es hier gar nicht
genauso wie auch beim Marmorkuchen oder
beim Zitronenkuchen oder bei meinem
schokonusskuchen wird auch dieser sehr
sehr saftig aber wir machen heute einen
hellen Nusskuchen denn der fehlt noch
auf meinem Kanal der ist sehr lecker so
dafür habe ich direkt einen Geheimtipp
für euch wir brauchen für das Rezept
natürlich gemahlene Haselnüsse und auch
wenn z.B ähm im Supermarkt in der
back-abteilung steht ja dann auch drauf
gemahlen und geröstet röstet es trotzdem
noch mal zu Hause es ist noch mal ein
ganz anderes Ergebnis wenn ihr keine
Zeit habt könnt ihr das auch so zum Teig
geben und falls ihr euch fragt wo die
ganz genau genommen stehen die schreiben
wir unten in die Videobeschreibung damit
das Video nicht so lang hat mich wird
ihr euch direkt einen Screenshot machen
könnt Einkaufen könnt und das Rezept
nachmachen könnte so ich nehme jetzt
hier noch mal so ein Bänder und dann
wird das hier bei Stufe 6 von 9 gleich
gehe ich auch runter auf 500 damit sich
zu heiß ist angeröstet ihr merkt es
nicht unbedingt an der Farbe sondern
eher am Geruch wenn es extrem nussig
riecht auch von dieser Entfernung dann
ist es perfekt dann kommt die Ladung
raus und die nächste Ladung rein
[Musik]
so wie gesagt dieser Schritt ist
wirklich optional wenn ihr gerade in
Eile seid und keine Zeit habt könnt ihr
das auch weglassen aber vertraut mir
dieses Aroma was da noch mal durchkommt
macht sich im ganzen Kuchen später
bemerkbar und wir versuchen ja aus allen
so das Beste rauszuholen jetzt nehmen
wir uns zum Beispiel auch Butter ich
persönlich finde also ihr könnt auch
Margarine nehmen ich persönlich finde
das hier einfach ein bisschen besser der
Geschmack drin steckt also Butter am
besten Zimmer waren hier in die Schüssel
geben und da könnt ihr auch schon Zucker
mit dazu geben
weil das kann dann zusammen richtig
schön cremig geschlagen werden ich gebe
auch schon Vanilleextrakt mit dazu
einfach ein Geschmack der super zu
Haselnüsse passt so da braucht ihr jetzt
auch nicht viel weil das schon sehr
intensiv schmeckt so und ihr könnt
natürlich eure Geräte benutzen ne ich
brauche jetzt keine Küchenmaschine aber
so geht's jetzt in meinem Fall einfach
ein bisschen schneller ein bisschen
einfacher das ganze wird dann richtig
schön hell cremig geschlagen
so nach ca zweieinhalb Minuten mit der
Maschine seht das ganze so aus also es
ist schon sehr hell geworden ist zum
cremige Masse und da geben wir jetzt
nacheinander die Eier dazu und rühren
die nacheinander so lange ein bis sie
sich mit der Masse verbunden haben dafür
wechsel ich jetzt hier aber mein Aufsatz
also es ist jetzt wirklich sehr angenehm
wie gesagt wenn ihr eine ein
Handrührgerät habt habt ihr meistens nur
diesen einen Aufsatz ist es auch okay es
klappt also ihr müsst euch da jetzt
keine Sorgen machen das ist dann nicht
klappt so ich nehme jetzt hier aber mein
Schneebesen Aufsatz weil sich damit
jetzt nicht nur die Eier sondern auch
gleich die trockenen Zutaten einfach
angenehmer im Teig voll und gerade bei
trockenen Zutaten sollte man immer nur
so lange mixen bis sich gerade so
verbunden hat und nicht übermixen weil
wir so einfach das beste Ergebnis
bekommt soll ich mache jetzt folgendes
die Eier die sind bei mir übrigens
Zimmer warm
wenn sie frisch aus dem Kühlschrank
kommt auch okay aber wenn sie auf
Zimmertemperatur sind dann verbindet
sich das besser mit der Masse und jetzt
gebe ich das immer nacheinander zu ähm
zur Masse und so könnt ihr immer gucken
ob noch eine Eierschale mit drin ist
oder nicht ich weiß ich mag das auch
gerne direkt in den Teig zu geben aber
ihr sagt ja immer klicke hier können
Eier schon alle drin sein und deswegen
hier noch mal mein Tipp einfach vorher
hier aufschlagen dann zur Masse geben
und kurz einrühren
[Musik]
und jetzt machen wir folgendes also
unsere Haselnüsse sind ja hier auch
schon abgekühlt und wir sollten jetzt
nicht warm da rein aber das geht ganz
schnell ich habe es auch extra in so
eine größere Auflaufform gegeben und
jetzt machen wir folgendes wir geben
jetzt das müsste jetzt in dem Fall auch
nicht sieben weil das gar keinen Sinn
ergeben würde tatsächlich hier gibt es
einfach alles so ein bisschen parallel
und nacheinander mit dazu zusammen mit
etwas Milch ganz wichtig ist dass ihr
das abwechselnd macht ne also dass sie
wirklich ist sie so trockene Zutaten
rein geht und während das ganze dann bei
niedriger Geschwindigkeit ein paar
Sekunden rührt gebe ich dir die Milch
dazu die habe ich in der Mikrowelle so
ein bisschen erwärmt damit sie jetzt
auch die gleiche Temperatur hat und da
eben auch nicht so ein großer
Temperaturunterschied ist dann verbindet
sich das besser und jetzt hier auch
nicht alles auf einmal reingehen soll
wirklich nur so ein Stückchen das hat
einfach den folgenden Grund dass ich das
alles besser in der Masse vermengt
so wenn ihr jetzt erst die trockenen
Zutaten komplett dazu geben würdet und
dann die Milch dann habt ihr einfach nur
so eine kompakte sehr Teigmasse und wir
wollen ja dass die saftig also dass der
Teig richtig saftig wird und dann machen
wir das hier schön abwechselnd
[Musik]
so eigentlich ist die Masse jetzt schon
fertig aber wir werden ja nicht die Kiki
Unity wenn wir das jetzt hier nicht
nochmal so richtig pimpen also bis
hierhin ist der Teig wirklich schon
super saftig nach dem Backen und ich
werde jetzt hier einfach noch
Haselnusskuchen mit reingeben ich muss
ehrlich sagen jetzt äh ohne dass es so
werbelastisch sein soll aber ganz
ehrlich alle die man gucken kann
probiert haben wissen jetzt was ich
meine wenn ihr das nur so vergleicht mit
mit diesem handelsüblichen Krokant
allein schon Optik ist ganz anders und
auch bei uns im Café sagt immer nimmt
euch als Topping noch eure Hand weil der
ist einfach der ist einfach so richtig
aromatisch so richtig crunchy und nicht
so von Zucker übersehen also wie soll
ich euch das erklären ihr habt so eine
süße knackige Haselnuss und nicht nur
Zuckerkristalle im Mund jetzt gebe ich
jetzt noch mit rein das ist tatsächlich
optional aber ich finde es richtig geil
und das sind halt auch die Haselnüsse
aus Auto aus der schwarzen Kiste
merkt man auch so viel Werbung muss
jetzt einfach sein weil die echt genial
sind so die rühre ich jetzt hier noch
mal ganz kurz ein und dann kommt es auch
schon in meine Form und anschließend
wird unser Kuchen gebacken bei 180 Grad
Ober und Unterhitze für 50 bis 55
Minuten
[Musik]
so der Kuchen ist jetzt abgekühlt und
jetzt können wir ihn aus der Form
entfernen nehmt euch am besten so eine
schmale Winkelpalette und geht
vorsichtshalber an einigen Stellen hier
am Rand entlang genau und dann einfach
lösen und auf eine schöne Servierplatte
stellen und dann fehlt noch der
haselnussguss und ganz ehrlich das ist
eine stallvorlage denn natürlich gibt's
auch fertigen Haselnuss Guss zu kaufen
aber der kommt geschmacklich nicht mal
ein Prozent an die Haselnusscreme rein
und die könnt ihr natürlich auch als
Guss verwenden also wenn ihr das da habt
oder ich schnappt sie Euch bei Kaufland
denn diese cream gibt's eigentlich auch
in Einkaufen Filialen wenn mal nicht
dann könnt ihr eine Information Fragen
aber wir beliefern alle Zentrallager das
heißt es liegt eigentlich nur noch ähm
an der Filialleitung das zu bestellen
und dann bekommt das auch und das könnt
ihr einfach für ein paar Sekunden in der
Mikrowelle erwärmen natürlich den die
goldene Folie auch abnehmen den Deckel
abnehmen und dann bei 600 Watt wirklich
nur so 15 Sekunden 20 vielleicht und
dann könnt ihr das nämlich einfach drauf
fließen lassen und dann wird es nämlich
auch wieder fest also nicht knackig fest
sondern angenehm fest wenn ihr das noch
mal in den Kühlschrank stellt oder
einfach generell Erkalten lasst
[Musik]
Salz fehlt natürlich nur noch so ein
knackiges Topping und da könnt ihr jetzt
natürlich entweder solche Haselnüsse
nehmen die hier sind jetzt noch mit
Schale ich muss sagen mir persönlich
immer ein bisschen bitter wenn ihr die
habt dann röstet sie gerne oder ihr
gönnt euch unsere Haselnusskerne das
sind jetzt der schwarzmeerkiste die
gleichen die hier drin stecken übrigens
wie gesagt die sind hier schon doppelt
geröstet und so richtig schön
luftdicht verschweißt und die kann ich
jetzt einfach nur noch hacken und auf
meine auf mein Kuchen geben und dann ist
auch schon fertig
[Musik]
also ich muss sagen der letzte
klassische Kuchen den ich gemacht habe
bei der Zitronenkuchen boah meine
Galerie meine Galerie explodiert also
das haben so viele nachgemacht
explodiert
diese leicht trockenen Kuchen
ist so unberechtigt weil es ist so
trocken weil keine Cremefüllung ist ne
aber ist trotzdem saftig
ne ne
das ist so ein intensiver
Haselnussgeschmack richtig gut
[Applaus]
[Musik]
also der ist wirklich sehr locker aber
dennoch halt saftig es schmeckt nicht so
trocken das ist mir ganz wichtig bei
solchen Kuchen
aber ich glaube der ist auch Krokant und
kann das sein
natürlich noch mal den
Haselnussgeschmack und dass wir das ähm
haselnussmehl also die gemahlenen
Haselnüsse haben wir vorher angeröstet
das sind halt diese Feinheiten die das
ausmachen ne also echt gut ich finde das
auch perfekt mit der Creme ja finde ich
auch man kann auch andere Cremes nehmen
ne ne nicht dass die Leute sagen man
muss nehmen dann müsste nicht ihr könnt
auch eine andere nehmen aber da habt ihr
natürlich sind kein geschmacklich muss
ich wirklich sagen kein Bashing oder
sowas unterscheidet sich das wissen aber
alle die die das mal wirklich so
verglichen haben und ganz ehrlich da bin
ich auch super stolz darauf natürlich
auch auf unsere Zutaten dass die Nüsse
die wir benutzen extra gut und doppelt
geröstet sind das wisst ihr auch ich
glaube deswegen ist der große Bruder von
der ganzen cream family habe genug über
die cream family gesprochen erzählt mir
gerne mal welches Standardrezept ihr von
mir als nächstes sehen möchtet genau
schreibt es mir gerne in die Kommentare
weil eigentlich entstehen so alle Videos
so die meisten eigentlich nur durch
euren Input also gerne gerne schreiben
und dann sehen wir uns auch beim
nächsten mal so machen
mein kalten Cappuccino den trinke ich
jetzt noch aus und dann mache ich mir
einen neuen heißen und dann wird sich
gegönnt ne übrigens heute morgen gemacht
immer noch der also bist du nächstes Mal
[Musik]